over the last two years we saw a raging
bull market asset prices went to the
moon as the feds stepped in and were
dropping monetary stimulus all over the
market but of course starting in
november of last year the federal
reserve they started talking about
quantitative tightening they said they
were going to raise interest rates and
they were going to take that persistent
bid that they had been presenting to the
market they were going to remove it all
of a sudden asset prices went into a
free fall and we have just seen down
only since november bitcoin obviously
down about 50 percent but it already
gone down 50 percent it hit that mark
back in january there was a little bit
of a relief rally bitcoin going up
around 45 000
but here we find ourselves back again in
the low 30 thousands and bitcoin 50 off
that all-time high of 69 000 back in
november now why exactly is this so
important well it's because investors
are horrible at controlling their
emotions if we take a look at something
like the fear and greed index right now
it's showing 11. there's fear everywhere
now this is fascinating to think about
because at 33 000 to have an 11 on the
fear and greed scale means that there's
tons and tons of people they're really
nervous they don't know what that
uncertain future looks like and so
naturally they're capitulating but the
last time that we hit 33 000 when we
went on the way up back at the beginning
of 2021 the fear and greed index showed
massive greed all over the place
same price this time fearful last time
greedy now all that tells us is that
perception is everything it's the same
asset and it's the same price for the
asset it's all just relative comparisons
to where the asset has been and where
people think that it's going now
ultimately when things get good people
get over excited they tend to think that
it's only going to get better and when
things get bad they tend to get overly
scared and they tend to think it's going
to get way worse than it actually does i
don't know the future any more than
anyone else but what i do know is that
one of the key ingredients to being a
great investor over long periods of time
is to learn to control your emotions
it's never as good as it seems it's
never as bad as it seems and as the old
saying goes this too shall pass now
ultimately as we see fear everywhere
that doesn't necessarily mean that we're
at the bottom of the market but what it
does tell us is that usually if you go
ahead and you buy assets when everyone
else is fearful and they're good assets
and their assets that you can hold for
decades to come it usually has a great
payoff along with it now naturally being
a contrarian is hard humans are sheep
they go with the crowd right now the
crowd is telling you bitcoin stocks and
other assets they're going down forever
i don't think that's necessarily what's
gonna happen i don't try to time markets
but what i do know if you can find those
great assets and you can hold them for a
long period of time the more people get
fearful the better off you're probably
gonna be if you've got cash and
liquidity and you start to buy in the
market it'd be fascinating to see how
the future plays out
the fear index at 11 that's pretty damn
low so let's see what happens but
ultimately
when there's blood in the streets it's
usually a good time to start getting
excited